l'abs et messieurs ma confiance en loïc
est morte en fait c'est pas vrai c'est
juste parce que c'est l intro vous
vouliez que je dis c'est que les vidéos
que vous choisissez l'intro et loïc tout
va bien entre nous mesdames et messieurs
en ce mois d'avril et nous allons
résoudre de nouveaux des casse-têtes non
pas un casse tête n'ont pas de casse
tête non pas 3 6 3 en fait trois
cachetées trois cadenas casse tête alors
je sais pas si je fais les trois dans la
vidéo parce que je ne sais pas la
difficulté si je vais bien galéré ou pas
du tout donc y en a 3 potentiel et je
vais quand même essayer de faire les
trois parce que parce que quoi loïc je
sais pas j'avais pas de fins de phrase
et je me suis dit c'est là où mon gars
sur mon ruia mon frère il va trouver des
mots au lit car ce genre de castel nord
moi je n'ai pas un temps de tournage
impunis parce que là bon on est mercredi
matin il est 6 heures du matin on le
sait c'est un doux réveil que de voir ma
vidéo le mercredi matin
mais ce soir je suis en spectacle à
cannes un spectacle tout à fait
particulier puisque j'ai avec moi soit
ne périsse et lola du mini céline h et
max bird et qu'on fait un gros plateau
en fête artistique à 4 donc venez et je
joue également mon spectacle à paris ça
fait très longtemps les 25 26 27 et 28
avril au théâtre de la tour eiffel 90%
des places ont été prises donc si vous
voulez venir bien dans la description
prenez briquet évidemment la tournée
continue à biarritz droit de villes
strasbourg morges en suisse etc
les liens sont dans la description toi
même tu sais c'est parti les casse tête
loïc génériques aujourd'hui on a avec un
cadenas qui s'ouvre et se referme
se déforme tu vois et qui rentre dans ma
tête et après je rentre dans le thé
parce que dans ma tête est aussi un
cadenas et je rentre dans le cas d'un
hacker dans ma tête je le des blocs et
ça débloque un troisième hémisphères du
cerveau qui était caché dans mes reins
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci beaucoup à toi tu es chez toi à
penser à tes souhaits fabien on va
commencer avec le premier casse tête
c'était peut-être ça qui arrive dans le
générique je ne sais pas qui est le haut
dit ni casse tête
pourquoi il ya marqué w ipl je ne sais
pas et ouais c'est lui le digne donc
j'ai jamais fait de cadenas casse tête
évidemment je trouve ça extrêmement
style est très jolie fabrication métal
remonte les manches parce que je sens
que ça va être bien chiant c'est un
nouveau concept de l'essai marqué 7
c'est du morse ça voulait dire 'ben toi
cette chaîne dont claudine y casse tête
bon ben moi je vais commencer très
classique en en faisant une petite phase
d'exploration sur tous les petits points
comme ceux ci qui n'ont pas vraiment
l'air de bouger il ya un trou ici dans
le fond là il ya un truc sur lequel peut
être on peut appuyer
non il ya deux cléac'h déjà est ce que
c'est les mêmes clés ou pas attention
observation loïc ma pipe
[Musique]
donc c'est lui au début un petit peu
ovale subi des litiges filiforme
mais néanmoins on lit se terminant par
une clé clé talent mais conclusions sont
formelles
c'est la même clé fin de la pluie bon on
va pas se mentir et un truc qui m'a
accroche l'oeil depuis tout à l'heure
c'est ce petit bouton là là où je je
vois on est on le voit clairement
regarder dans cette caméra
regardez moi on voit clairement qu'un
petit point là est ce que je peux vous
faire voir de près ce petit point voilà
je parle de ce petit point là on voit la
queue on peut appuyer dessus on voit que
c'est un espace complètement avoue vite
donc on va essayer d'appuyer dessus
attention je redescends eux par contre
ils peuvent alors quand tu n'arrives pas
avec le doigt tu prends un accessoire
que tu as près de toi par exemple une
clé jeu à tanger même pas essayer de
l'ouvrir avec tu vas laisser ça le truc
mais vraiment je crois que je peux faire
des heures sans essayer de faire cette
chose très basique qui est de m quand
même la clé dans la serrure
bon évidemment ça marche pas donc si
vous appuyez sur un bouton qui se passe
pas grand chose ce que tu crois qu'il
faut appuyer fort que ça se bouge pas ça
peut-être en appuyant plus fort ok deux
choses se passent en moi
la première du contentement qu'est ce
que c'est malin d'avoir caché une
serrure sous ce petit bloc donkey que je
n'arrive pas à refermer l'air aouissi
d'accord faut appuyer fin et donc si on
appuie là oui j'espère qu'on a un joli
cadre ici alors dans ce cas là attention
je vais réappuyer très fortement une
trappe secrète s'ouvre la deuxième chose
qui se passe en moi c'est de me dire ben
je crois que il est terminée suis là
j'imagine qu'avec n'ont pas forcément
facile voilà il est complètement ouvert
complètement terminée d'accord il
suffisait juste d'établir une trappe
secrète de l'ouvrir et on pouvait
accéder à la petite erreur de base ok
pas très compliqué parce que le bouton
est visible et c'est ce truc qu'on voit
néanmoins c'est un cadenas de bonne
facture en métal et ça peut donc servir
de britten là je trouve ça cool quoi tu
vois ok le houdini casse tête qu'est ce
qu'on a faits loïc tu as well
[Musique]
deuxième cadenas attention ils sont
rangés par ordre de difficulté lui étant
le plus dur on va passer aux cannes nat
du paon cadenas du paon parce que lié à
un pan dessus on a trois clés qui sont
fournis comme tout à l'heure on va
regarder si les clés sont identiques
loïc ma pipe
effectué créneau fait le chrono pays
chrono record dans un petit trou petit
trop petit trou mais conclusions sont
formelles même plaît alors là
contrairement tout à l'heure on va quand
même essayer de mettre la clé dans la
serrure a alors contrairement à tout à
l'heure là quand je mets la clé dans la
serrure
je sens bien que c'est tout à fait
adapté dire que ça marche
elle s'en font du bien et ça tourne et
là j'ai une résistance à ce moment là je
sens que cette clé aimerait pouvoir
aller plus loin ce qui n'était pas le
cas tout à l'heure c'est normal c'était
pas la bonne serrure mais là je pense
pas qu'ils aient de serrures quelques
cachets ils n'ont pas cassé
si ça vous fait plaisir de revoir une
petite vidéo casse tête et que vous
voulez qu'on a en face comme ça de temps
en temps n'hésitez pas quand même à
liker cette vidéo mais rien qui bouge là
j'aimerais assez coûteux cuit ça c'est
terrible
il ya un truc de ouf c'est que quand tu
viens de faire un casse tête tu as
l'impression que le suivant ça va être
exactement la même solution tu sais que
non mais tu as quand même envie
d'essayer mais tu sais que non mais si
tu es c'est pas bête est pas bien en
fond de toi ça fait pas le poids la
taille non et s'il ya dans ce trou 1 je
vois la serrure de notre côté loïc je te
vois
miss l'oïdium et dont il ya le pan ti
soit vous faire voir quand même soin et
péter puisque
ah je crois pas qu'ils se les est ce
qu'il va en butée soit sous x davis soit
c'est la solution mais comme c'est le
seul truc qui bouge je pense vraiment
que c'est la solution
donc il était comment au départ il était
comme ça là sa force un peu mais je peux
pas rentrer la création comme ça si je
le tourne à fond si c'est ça c'est pas
beaucoup
on espère que ce soit ça et en même
temps on espère que ce ne soit pas
ah non non d'accord alors peut-être
après il faut le remettre dans l'autre
sens pour essayer de refaire un autre
tour tu vois ce que je veux dire ou pas
attends je vais pas mis à fond à fond là
on était comme ça on a fait un tour à
droite peut-être pour faire un tour à
gauche peut-être un truc qui brainfuck
la ya forcément un système d'alerté tour
ou deux il ya au moins une autre étape
au minimum donc là c'est ce que j'ai
fait à l'heure un coup est-ce qu'on peut
enfin on peut en faire un deuxième
[Musique]
à la semaine prochaine
cette solution était incroyablement
difficile il fallait retourner le paon
et donné deux tours de clé et ainsi nous
obtenions une ouverture de cadenas bon
c'est pareil pas hyper hyper excitant
sympa quand même
mais pas hyper hyper excitant et en plus
le côté un peu secret du truc bon le pan
vraiment il ya que ça qui bouge moi je
m'attendais vraiment à faire un falloir
faire avant arrière retour après ce sont
des castels coût de 10 euros donc je
m'attendais pas à une fabrication de
poussière je crois il était peut-être
quand même mais bo kay lui par contre il
paraît qu'il est dur on va voir ce que
pour l'instant ça allait avant d'entamer
de castets le plus dur de la série là
par contre c'est le loch je sais plus
quoi 4 vous avez des liens vers tous les
cas cités dans la description je vous
invite néanmoins à cliquer ici
enfin pas ici sur l'écran en fait c'est
le bouton s'abonner
et bien si ce style de vidéos vous plaît
vous vous prenez votre bain et vous
cliquez sur le bouton s'abonner
allez-y c'est important nous oublié de
vous abonner et ce à ses abonnés
bon c'est parti le je sais pas si tu as
mis un générique ou un casse-tête 3 mais
j'imagine que tu as mis quelque chose
comparaison des clés sans surprise
depuis tout à l'heure ce sont les mêmes
j'entends les gens qui se plaignent en
commentaire est ce qu'à un moment donné
pour la communauté faut faire des
efforts alors je le regarde le mieux
même chose même chose même le vin c'est
la m on va chercher un truc qui bouge
comme tout à l'heure les points ne bouge
pas ça on se rend bien compte que c'est
un peu amovible un sap eu un petit effet
ressort il ya comme sur une voiture
marche arrière 1 2 3 4 5
ici sur le tour il n'ya rien évidemment
là il ya comme un truc mais pauvre - de
ses cibles
ok donc a que ça qui bouge
est-ce que la clé rentrent dans la
serrure de oui mais alors là un petit
peu comme le premier je peux pas du tout
bougé dedans
et ça ça bouge un peu il ya un mois non
mais c'est rien je pense que ça c'est
juste du jeu loïc ouais j'ai un tout
petit soucis il ya vraiment strictement
rien qui bouge toi tu mets ta pipe manga
c'est toi c'est yao au toit tu fais ta
toute la main
il ya peut-être un truc dedans on a déjà
eu des casses têtes comme ça avait il ya
des castes à tout va les taper
je sais pas par où commencer
[Musique]
d'ici à trouver un petit bouton caché là
dessous j'ai pas envie de forcer comme
un malade mental mais là lui sort bien
de ce côté quoi et un petit feu mais
voilà c'est des loquets et nous accédons
à une c'est alors qu'est ce que je sais
pas comme j'ai espoir c'est si c'est là
la vrai truc ou pas en fait je vous dis
je passe eux ça mais ce pourrait être
autre chose mais j'imagine que c'est
fait pour dans le petit interstice qu'on
peut voir ici juste là ce petit
interstice la jeu juste je le mets
dedans pour forcer un tout petit shui et
south direct mais je vois pas de bouton
je sais pas comment ça fonctionne et
avec la preuve des doigts ainsi à web
même avec lafarge les doigts si vraiment
parfum de cette galère
à l'heure actuelle j'arrive même pas le
refaire je pense que c'est fait pour
faire ça en fait dès qu'il ya dès qu'il
ya une force qui est appliqué là ça
ouvre et donc nous avons vu quoi dedans
enfin ça ouvrait on a vu une serrure
secrète ça nous rappelle le houdini
skype
aussi je donne à petit trou de serrure
justin et ça marche il était cool
celui-là était plus compliqué parce que
yahvé y avait pas c'était moins logique
en fait que le pan j'ai bien galéré une
demi heure je pense en tout elle réalisé
bonne demi heure alors oui vous avez
dure une demi-heure ses banques ou
fabien pour un truc avec une seule étape
oui mais quand t'as jamais fait des
cadenas tas je me fais des cadenas 1
comme on dit quand t'as jamais fait
exactement loïc merci beaucoup
comme d'habitude je voulais faire gagner
ses trois casquettes je vais pas le
garder pour moi donc je voulais fait
gagner sur mon instinct g
vous allez voir la photo qui est ici
vous lisez tout est expliqué sur comment
le gagner je fais le tirage au sort la
semaine prochaine sa part directement
chez vous les trois d'un coup voilà
comme ça vous savez déjà comment les
réseaux en plus est extrêmement pratique
à la question y aura-t-il fabien des
castes et sur le chêne secondaire
beaucoup d'entre vous se disent quoi m
shon secondaire j'étais pas au courant
vous n'avez pas regardé la dernière
vidéo c'est pour ça à regarder la
dernière vidéo je vous la met ici et
vous avez la chaîne secondaire dans la
description on retrouve un peu le mood
de 2016 avec des vidéos un peu plus
rapide plus corps qui sortent n'importe
quand vous êtes 20000 à vous êtes abonné
venez venez on se retrouve là bas pour
information il ya une vidéo qui est
sorti aujourd'hui sur le pouvoir de
décision parce que on sait depuis assez
peu de temps que notre cerveau décide 11
secondes avant qu'on ait fait notre
choix c'est chelou j'en ai fait une
petite vidéo parce que c'était très
intéressant
allez voir ça d'ailleurs merci d'avoir
regardé celle-ci laïque et si elle vous
a plu pour vous abonner vous pouvez
cliquer là la chaîne secondaire vous
pouvez cliquer là la vidéo de la chaîne
secondaire ici et ça c'est la dernière
vidéo qui est sorti sur cette chaîne ça
fait quoi faire des gros bisous à très
bientôt ciao